a key player in the negotiations for a
coronavirus relief bill the Treasury
secretary Stephen minuchin mr. secretary
welcome back to Fox News Sunday good to
see you you were up on Capitol Hill all
day yesterday you're expected to be up
there again today we hear that this
package is now 1.8 trillion dollars and
may go above it is this going to get
done and if so when will it get done
well thank you for having me here and I
do think it will get done we've been
working around the clock in the Senate
with the Republicans and the Democrats
I've been speaking to Mitch McConnell
Chuck Schumer the speaker and I think we
have a fundamental understanding and we
look forward to wrapping it up today let
me let me just walk you through the
highlights of the package because the
president is very determined to protect
American workers we've ordered a major
part of the economy to shut down and the
president wants to protect them so the
first part are what I call small
business retention loans if you're a
small business you'll get two weeks of
cash flow to pay your workers you need
to retain them you'll also get some
overhead and if you do that those loans
will be forgiven that's about half of
our workforce that will allow small
businesses to keep people and make sure
when we open the economy they're up and
running the second part is direct
deposits the average direct deposit or
check for a family of four will be
approximately $3,000 this you can think
of is a bridge for them to get through
this quickly the third component is
enhanced unemployment insurance for
people that are laid off due to the
coronavirus and the fourth component is
a significant package working with the
Federal Reserve will have up to four
trillion dollars of liquidity that we
can use to support the economy and
that's it those are broad-based
lending programs under Section thirteen
three we can leverage our equity working
with the Federal Reserve and then on top
of it the president is determined
hospitals need money there's a very
significant amount of money for
hospitals and medical professionals last
I heard that for the hospitals it was a
hundred and ten billion dollars is that
what you're looking at still that's
approximately where we're gonna go
shading the final numbers but we want to
make sure the hospitals have money the
best way to get through this is for us
to win this war with this virus let me
ask you this question because liquidity
is is key here and and what we've heard
so far with this bill and maybe it's
changed in the last 24 hours that was
the liquidity assistance really was
sectoral a lot of it go to the Airlines
cruise ship industry hotel industry now
the auto industry has got its hand out
as well whereas you there are people who
say that it really needs to be
broad-based across the entire economy
where are you on that front
well I think as you know when this
started this was a bit unique to the
airline's industry since we had shut
down most of airline travel but now that
we're we've shut down major parts of the
economy this liquidity facility is is a
broad-based liquidity facility working
with the feds so there there is a small
component for airlines national security
companies but there's a very broad-based
as I said we can lever up to four
trillion dollars to help everything from
small businesses to big businesses get
through the next 90 to 120 days as we
win this war let me ask you about this
direct deposit you said three thousand
dollars for a family of four that's
about a thousand dollars per adult that
500 per child that was one of the
formulas that was floating around last
week senator Bernie Sanders of Vermont
also continues to be a presidential
candidate saying that's nowhere near
enough listen to how he put it
what in God's name does a $600 check or
a $2,000 check
mean one time when you are unemployed
yes it may get you through three weeks
maybe stretch it you get you through a
month but that is nowhere near what the
working people of this country I need
and should have mr. secretary you have
suggested in the past and other White
House officials have as well that this
idea of a direct payment may come in two
different tranches one on April the 6th
another one may be on May 18th are you
still looking at that or is this a
one-time only payment well for now in
this legislation it is one payment but
let me just say these three pieces all
tied together workers will get money
through the small business
program again through retention they'll
get money through unemployment and
they'll get effectively this bridge
check payment which is really a direct
deposit so these three programs all work
very quickly and if for whatever reason
with you know ten weeks from now this
virus we haven't won this will go back
to Congress again but I think we're
injecting a lot of liquidity into the
system and hardworking Americans know
that the president wants to protect them
and we're doing everything to support
them I was going to just ask you that
question that is what what is the
timeframe in which this stimulus package
is designed to work is it six weeks
eight weeks you mentioned just a second
ago ten weeks I well first of all I hope
this gets passed on Monday because we
need the money now you know I would say
we're looking at this from anywhere to a
10 to 12 week scenario but again this
situation is moving quickly we need to
get the money into the economy now if we
do that we think we can stabilize the
economy we're putting a lot of money
into the hospitals and you know I think
the president has every expectation that
this is going to look a lot better for
eight weeks from now right so so if this
does go beyond ten weeks because I mean
we've seen what the infection curve is
like in South Korea we've seen it in
China we don't know what it's like here
in the United States particularly in in
New York City if after ten weeks
businesses still have to remain closed
and nobody's flying on the airlines or
staying in hotel rooms can you keep
going back to the well Larry Kudlow has
suggested that with interest rates the
way they are borrowing is basically a
bottomless pit but I mean how much debt
can you take on to address this well I
think the good news is the US economy is
strong okay we've stopped major parts of
it but when we get through this virus as
I've said I think you're gonna see the
US economy come back to the strength we
have great companies we have great
workers what we need to do is have a
bridge to get through this and this
isn't the financial crisis that's going
to go on for years so I've been
listening to the medical professionals I
think there's a lot of advances that are
being made on different types of
treatments we're gonna do whatever week
we need to do to win this
and I think this bill gives us a lot of
money to create a lot of liquidity in
the system and protect Americans and if
this lasts longer we'll come back again
all right you said that the economy is
strong you expect it to bounce back but
how long can we stay in the situation we
are in now before this temporary damage
becomes permanent because there are a
lot of smaller businesses that are going
under day-by-day because they can't stay
open they can't pay their people and
even the financial assistance isn't
going to help them out well this
financial assistance will help them out
so approximately 50% of the economy is
small businesses and what we're doing
here is we're providing the liquidity
for those small businesses many of which
have zero revenues to give them money to
pay their workers to pay their rent to
pay their electricity it is that go to
cover everybody I mean there were an
awful lot of small businesses here now
that we'll cover you know kind of
roughly half of the the private
workforce and yes in most cases its its
companies 500 or or less but yes that's
going to cover roughly half the the
workforce and as I said for bigger
companies we have liquidity facilities
we'll have enhanced unemployment
insurance again just for the coronavirus
but we want to make sure that workers
are paid are we currently mr. secretary
in a recession I think that's a
technical question that in this
situation is not terribly relevant you
know are we going to have reduced
economic activity this quarter
absolutely I think next quarter a lot
depends on how quickly the curve of the
medical situation works but you know
when people focus on recessions it's
normally because of a prolonged economic
environment this is a very unique
situation that we've never had before
this is the government has self-imposed
shutting down large parts of the economy
and as soon as we can get the medical
situation under control we're going to
reopen it and to the extent we've we've
kept all these small businesses in
business we've kept workers with them
when we reopen the economy the economy
is going to bounce back significantly
the Washington Post reported yesterday
that the intelligence community was
giving the White House warnings
back in January and early February that
the situation coming out of China was
very very serious and would likely end
up into pandemic we're where were you
over at the Treasury Department ever
warned that something like this was
coming down the pike because the initial
White House reaction appeared to be oh
don't worry it's over there in China I
was told why do we need to respond
robustly because there's only 16 cases
here
were you ever warned early on by the
intelligence community that this was
coming you know I want to be careful
talking about specific intelligence but
but let me be clear and this is not just
in the US this is this is around the
world nobody expected this to take off
at the rate it it did and and even as
you know I've now been on the task force
listening to the medical professionals
for a long period of time I said a few
weeks ago you know I felt comfortable
traveling on commercial airfare I did
the situation has changed very quickly
and the president has responded to that
you know as we saw the spread here we
shut down airline travel abroad with
Europe that was a very important move
and as we've seen States we've been
working with the states in recommending
this so I don't think anybody should
second-guess the government actions this
has been moving very quickly and I think
we've responded appropriately the
defense production act the president
basically activated it but he hasn't yet
put it into practice but we have states
like Michigan and so many others and
we're going to talk to the governor of
Michigan coming up a little bit later
who are in desperate need of medical
supplies General Motors is volunteering
to make ventilators but does the
president need to pull the trigger on
the defense production act and say
industry get out there and make this
equipment because we're running behind
this is only going to get worse before
it gets better and we need you to step
up to the plate now well I know the task
force is very focused on supply chains
quite frankly I'm full-time focused
right now on the economic side of this
we have other people working on the
supply chains but I have every
confidence that the president has these
powers he's working with private
industry and we're expediting this as
quickly as possible just before we go
when do you expect
vote on this fiscal stimulus package
Monday morning all right secretary
minuchin is always thanks for your time
and see at the White House tomorrow
we'll keep an eye on the action at
Capitol Hill
thank you very much